in defense of pick a pop-culture figure  or something you're super passionate  about that maybe gets a bad rap but you  need to defend coffee I defend coffee to  my dying day I have tried to stop and I  can't and I now embrace it it keeps me  alive it keeps me sane it keeps me  remembering my lines some people call  coffee performance in a cup and I am one  of them what's your go-to coffee are you  like espresso you like black coffee so I  like it all I mean I really like it all  as long as it's not weak and dish watery  i love it i like it dark i do not like a  lot of cream or milk or sugar i have to  admit i am like with the caffeine thanks  for watching ET on youtube there's  plenty more great content all you got to  do is click to subscribe  you